Hey there, Shankar here. I wanted to give you a heads up that I have a new book out. It's called Useful Delusions, and it looks at the paradox of self-deception. There are many ways deceiving ourselves can produce bad outcomes, but sometimes self-deception can also produce good outcomes. As I was thinking about this counterintuitive idea in my own life, I began to reflect on a personal story. It's about my parents, and I thought I'd share it with you as a Valentine's Day bonus
大家好，我是香卡。我想先通知大家，我出了一本新书。书名叫《有用的妄想》，它探讨了自欺欺人的悖论。欺骗自己有很多方式可能会导致不好的结果，但有时自欺欺人也能带来好的结果。当我思考生活中这种反直觉的想法时，我开始反思一个个人故事。这是关于我父母的，我想作为情人节特别节目分享给你们
episode. My parents were married for 46 years. Right up until my dad died 10 years ago, he lived by a simple maxim. On all matters, big and small, my mother was right. When she embarked on difficult personal journeys, it was because they were necessary. When she took daring professional leaps and suffered great setbacks, they were only temporary. In every conflict and argument in which my mother found herself embroiled. My dad was on her side. This wasn't a strategic decision he made to purchase domestic harmony. He genuinely
。我父母结婚46年了。直到10年前我父亲去世前，他一直遵循一个简单的信条：无论大事小事，我母亲总是对的。当她踏上艰难的个人旅程时，那是因为这是必要的；当她进行大胆的职业跨越并遭受重大挫折时，那些都只是暂时的。在我母亲卷入的每一场冲突和争论中，我父亲都站在她这边。这不是他为了维持家庭和谐而做出的战略决定，他是发自内心地
thought of her as the Delphiocorical. He was all in. Regardless of whether such unswarving fate was good for my mother, I've come to realize it was very good for my father. His delusional belief in her allowed him to lead a very happy married life. If my mother were a psychopath, having such a loyal conspirator could have led to disaster. But in the ordinary choices that families make, where to live, how to raise children, what to eat for dinner. My father's simple faith in my mother's infallibility meant many important decisions got made quickly, easily, and without recrimination.
认为她至高无上。他是全心全意投入的。无论这种坚定不移的信念对母亲是否有利，我渐渐意识到这对我父亲大有裨益。他对母亲近乎妄想的信任让他过上了非常幸福的婚姻生活。如果我母亲是个精神病患者，拥有这样一个忠诚的同谋可能会导致灾难。但在家庭做出的日常选择中，比如住在哪里、如何抚养孩子、晚饭吃什么，我父亲对我母亲绝对正确性的简单信仰，意味着许多重要决策得以迅速、轻松且毫无指责地做出。
Many couples unwittingly undermine each other because they lack such simple faith. This is especially true when both halves of a couple have strong views. When you think you're the expert on something and your partner does too, this can be a recipe for conflict. This is bad news when you consider we live in a world increasingly dominated by a sortative meeting, a fancy way of saying that people tend to marry others who are like themselves. This is why you have so many lawyers married to other
许多伴侣不知不觉地在互相拆台，因为他们缺乏这种简单的信仰。当双方都有强烈的观点时，情况尤其如此。当你认为自己是某个领域的专家，而你的伴侣也这么认为时，这往往会成为冲突的导火索。考虑到我们生活在一个越来越多地被“同类婚配”主导的世界里，这并不是什么好消息。“同类婚配”是一个fancy的说法，意思是人们倾向于与和自己相似的人结婚。这就是为什么你会看到那么多律师与
lawyers or writers married to other writers. Many dating apps, in fact, try to match you with people who are exactly like yourself, which is great, until you find that narcissism of small differences can turn trivial disagreements into vicious conflicts. You like Joseph Conrad? What are you? A Nazi? My father was spared all of that. He was convinced that his wife had impeccable taste in music and books, and that she was infallible when it came to how my sister and I were raised.
律师结婚，或者作家与作家结婚。事实上，许多约会软件试图将你与完全相同的人匹配，这本是件好事，直到你发现微小差异的自恋会将微不足道的意见分歧变成恶性的冲突。你喜欢约瑟夫·康拉德？你是什么人？纳粹吗？我父亲则免去了这一切。他坚信他的妻子在音乐和书籍方面有着无可挑剔的品味，而且在我和姐姐的抚养问题上，她总是正确的。
My father came from very humble beginnings and suffered great physical and professional setbacks in his life. But the anchor of his marriage, his belief that he was in an ideal marriage. MENT he died happy. To be clear, I'm not suggesting you should just hand over all your keys to your partner. Being overly trusting can sometimes get you in trouble. There is much to be said for evaluating partners carefully and thinking through whether you are compatible. Some people are better matches than others. When it comes to love, people who drive you nuts on day one are best avoided. But too many people, especially those who are highly educated, imagine that finding a partner
我父亲出身卑微，一生中遭受过巨大的身体和职业挫折。但婚姻的锚，即他坚信自己身处理想婚姻中的信念，意味着他带着幸福离世。需要明确的是，我并不是建议你把所有的钥匙都交出来。盲目信任有时会给你带来麻烦。仔细评估伴侣并思考你们是否合拍，这些都很有必要。有些人的契合度就是比其他人更高。谈到爱情时，那些第一天就让你抓狂的人最好还是避开。但太多人，尤其是那些受过高等教育的人，以为找到一个能
with whom they will be happy over a lifetime is a matter of insight. As they stare into a lover's eyes over a Valentine's Day dinner, they imagine it's possible to know whether they are with the right person. Sadly, this is impossible. Not only is your partner going to be very different 46 years down the line, you are going to be very different in a few decades. What you want now will not be what you want then. Over time, aspects of your personality will inevitably drive your partner bonkers, and
共度一生并感到幸福的伴侣是一个洞察力的问题。当他们在情人节晚餐时凝视着爱人的眼睛时，他们以为自己有可能知道眼前的人是否对的人。可悲的是，这是不可能的。不仅你的伴侣在46年后会发生巨大变化，你在几十年后也会面目全非。你现在想要的将不再是你当时想要的。随着时间的推移，你性格中的某些方面不可避免地会让你的伴侣抓狂，而且
no matter how compatible you think you are, any partner you choose will at some point cause you to question your judgment. Most relationships accordingly benefit from a certain degree of self-deception. At some point successful relationships involve transitioning from being with the one you want to wanting the one you're with. People in successful relationships are not those who have partners with no flaws. Rather, they are people who discount their partner's flaws and accentuate their partner's virtues. They embrace useful delusions about each other.
无论你认为你们有多合拍，你选择的任何伴侣在某个时刻都会让你质疑自己的判断。因此，大多数关系都受益于某种程度的自欺欺人。在某些时刻，成功的关系包括从“和你想在一起的人在一起”转变为“想要和你在一起的人”。成功关系中的人并不是那些伴侣没有缺点的人，而是那些忽略伴侣缺点并放大伴侣优点的人。他们拥抱彼此身上有用的妄想。
If you want to be happy, you can do worse than to have my father's simple faith in my mother. His wisdom, of course course is reflected in religious texts such as the passage from Corinthians that is often quoted in Marit ceremonies. Love is patient, love is kind. It does not envy, it does not boast, it is not proud. It is not rude, it is not self-seeking, it is not easily angered, it keeps no record of wrongs. If you are not religious, perhaps I can offer you a secular saint instead. Here is Ruth Bader Ginsburg's advice for a happy marriage. It helps sometimes to be a little death.
如果你想获得幸福，学学我父亲对母亲那种单纯的信念，效果不会比这更差了。当然，他的智慧反映在宗教文本中，比如《哥林多前书》中经常在婚礼上被引用的那段经文：爱是恒久忍耐，又有恩慈。爱是不嫉妒，爱是不自夸，不张狂，不做害羞的事，不求自己的益处，不轻易发怒，不计算人的恶。如果你没有宗教信仰，或许我可以为你提供一位世俗的圣人。以下是鲁斯·巴德·金斯伯格关于幸福婚姻的建议：有时候，装点聋作哑很有帮助。
I published the written version of this op-ed in the Los Angeles Times. You can find out more about how to make the paradox of self-deception work for you in my new book Useful Delusions, The Power and Paradox of the Self-Decieving Brain. Order the book by going to hiddenbrain.org slash books. Again, that's hiddenbrain.org slash books. And happy Valentine's Day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我在《洛杉矶时报》上发表了这篇专栏文章的网络版。你可以在我的新书《有用的妄想：自欺大脑的力量与悖论》中了解更多关于如何让自欺欺人的悖论为你所用。访问 hiddenbrain.org 斜杠 books 来订购本书。再次提醒，网址是 hiddenbrain.org 斜杠 books。祝大家情人节快乐。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。